[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the iphone 7 and we already know it
doesn't have a headphone jack anymore
just the lightning port so it does have
slightly improved speakers and you could
listen to those if you want to listen to
music or watch videos but the removal of
that headphone port means we now have
two real options for listening to music
via headphones lightning headphones and
wireless headphones fun fact apple
dropping a headphone jack from the
iphone 7 is actually great news for one
person or one group of people and that's
headphone manufacturers because they
just got a huge new market of people to
sell headphones to that didn't exist
before and that's iphone 7 buyer so as
this iphone comes out and it's brand new
the accessory market is young so if
you're going to be early to this phone
you got to be early to the accessories
so these are those accessories option
one lightning headphones so your default
option is the lightning earpods that
come in the box they're nothing special
but you can see obviously instead of
ending in a three and a half millimeter
headphone jack it's a lightning port so
plugs right in no charging required no
adapter required this is the standard
now everything else about them from the
earpods to the inline controller is the
same as before from the standard you can
go up a little bit in price to these
phillips headphones i've shown before
these are the philips fidelio m2 and
they're pretty much what you'd expect
from a classic third-party pair of
lightning headphones so a lightning jack
on one end on-ear headphones on the
other end and these headphones also have
an on cup volume control rocker and the
entire right ear cup is a giant play
pause button so it works the same way it
did with the previous iphones but yeah
now it's the primary option it's
standard plugging right into that
lightning port this is the other ovary
repair i've showed in a previous video
these are the audeze sign definitely a
more premium price but you're getting
better materials more real leather and
metal and a bit more of a heavier
headphone overall a softer headband more
comfortable but yeah this pair has an
inline controller with a mic and a play
pause button which is different and
volume controls etc this plugs right in
by lightning again and works as expected
sounds pretty good if you're more on a
budget though there are way less
expensive headphones i'll have links to
all these below but this is a pair by
bright tech inline controls again it's a
bit of a trend but honestly these are a
bit less adjustable and a lot less
comfortable but they're still lightning
headphones you'll just notice they
definitely feel cheaper and definitely
hurt in the sound department so it's
what you'd expect for the price but
really i'd recommend these to someone
who's trying to save money but just
definitely want over-ear headphones and
have to go on via lightning and last but
not least another pair of lightning
earbuds these are the shark lightning
earbuds their advantage over the
lightning ear pods are small they have
slightly bigger more clicky inline
controls and the flat blue cable
throughout is a nice touch helps it not
get tangled as much and the earbuds
themselves feel a bit more solid they
have what feels like metal on the back
and they have a little bit more weight
to them but as you know none of that
matters if they don't stay in your ears
very well and these didn't stay in my
ears very well all right so option
number two is wireless headphones this
market has already existed for a while
so all these headphones except for one
are new but the thing about wireless
headphones is you're never quite going
to match the level of sound quality you
get from wired but what you want to look
for in wireless headphones is a really
long battery life to hopefully alleviate
the inconvenience of having to charge
them so the default option here with the
iphone 7
is the new air pods you know the ones
the 159 dollar
earpods without wires they get a lot of
flack for it not being worth it but
actually they have a couple of extra
features so they have apple's new w1
chip inside which makes pairing to an
iphone super simple and then they
automatically also sync with your other
apple devices on your account like a
macbook pro or an ipad it has
microphones for listening to voice
commands and touch sensitivity for
triggering siri so there's a lot
actually going on hopefully i'll get my
hands on them to review them but there
are definitely other better options like
bluetooth earbuds any of them you've
seen these before jaybirds x2 or jaybird
freedom they have a battery life almost
twice as long as the air pods rated at
about eight hours of playback before you
need to recharge so that's awesome and
they sound phenomenal that's why i like
them so much and they're very unlikely
to fall out of your ears no matter what
the shape is because they have this
wingtip that fits snugly and comfortably
they're sweat proof they have a great
mic and in-line controls they're
basically built to be workout headphones
so they're really good at all of that
another pair you've probably seen before
since i've reviewed them is the bose
qc35 or the bose quietcomfort 35s the
quietcomfort series finally went
wireless and they are so nice they're
much bigger so you're looking at about a
20 hour battery life and they have
excellent noise cancellation because
that's basically bose's specialty here
and much better sound than most other
wireless headphones they're pricey but
if you watch the review you'll probably
also be convinced like i was and there
were also plenty of other wireless
headphones in this bluetooth over ear
category again check the links below and
then there's these the new beats solo 3.
they were announced alongside the new
iphone on stage since apple owns beats
now and they're still beats uh they're
on your wireless headphones and they
also have the new w1 chip inside them
like the airpods do so when you turn
them on they pair to your iphone really
easily like the air pods and in theory
the rest of your apple id devices as
well they talk with your iphone sending
information back and forth like battery
percentage so that's a nice advantage to
having them work so closely with apple
and what's nice though is they claim a
40 hour playback battery life which is a
really long time so there's no noise
cancellation to take up a lot of power
but that's a decent advantage having
such a long battery life not having to
worry about charging it so much just
know that they're still priced like
beats and they still sound like beats
just so you know so that's what's out
there right now if you want to avoid
having to adapt your current headphones
but if all else fails there is that nine
dollar dongle
i'm personally against dongles i don't
want to have to think about an adapter
every time i want to plug my headphones
in but worst case scenario you keep your
current pair of headphones and plug the
dongle in to the end and just leave it
there permanently that way hopefully you
won't lose it but listen this market
which is so small right now will grow a
lot in the next year like i want to say
99 of the companies who are making
headphones for iphone right now with the
three and a half millimeter jack
they'll probably all be making lightning
headphones to take advantage of this new
market within the next year pretty much
guaranteed so they can thank apple for
the huge new market to sell headphones
to
we can thank apple for
the inability to charge and listen to
wired music at the same time but here's
what i'd like to see in the next iphone
i know it's pretty early but i'd like to
see the next iphone have two lightning
ports and if someone wants to get in on
it early they can make an android phone
with two usb type-c ports i wouldn't
really care about the lack of headphone
jack as much
either way that's been it thank you for
watching i'll talk to you guys the next
one
peace
[Music]